in this segment we discussed the
expected value rule for calculating the
expected value of a function of a random
variable it corresponds to a nice
formula that we will see shortly but it
also involves a much more general idea
that we will encounter many times in
this course in somewhat different forms
here's what it is all about we start
with a certain random variable that has
a known PMF however were ultimately
interested in another random variable Y
which is defined as a function of the
original random variable we are
interested in calculating the expected
value of this new random variable Y how
should we do it we will illustrate the
ideas involved through a simple
numerical example in this example we
have a random variable X that takes
values 2 3 4 or 5 according to some
given probabilities you are also given a
function that map's X values into Y
values and this function G then defines
a new random variable so if the outcome
of the experiment leads to an X equal to
4 then our random variable Y will also
take a value equal to 4 how do we
calculate the expected value of y the
only tool that we have available in our
hands at this point
is the definition of the expected value
which tells us that we should run a
summation over the y axis consider
different values of y one at a time and
for each value of y multiply that value
by its corresponding probability so in
this case we start with y equal to 3
which needs to be multiplied by the
probability that y is equal to 3 what is
that probability well Y is equal to 3 if
and only if X is 2 or 3 which happens
with probability point 1 plus 0.2 then
we continue with the summation by
considering the next value of little Y
the next possible value is 4 and this
gives us a contribution of 4 weighted by
the probability of obtaining F for the
probability that Y is equal to 4 is the
probe
that X is either equal to 4 or to 5
which happens with probability point 3
plus point 4 so this way we obtain an
arithmetic expression which we can
evaluate and it's going to give us the
expected value of y but here's an
alternative way of calculating the
expected value and this corresponds the
following type of thinking 10 percent of
the time X is going to be equal to 2 and
when that happens Y takes on a value of
3 so this should give us a contribution
to the average value of y which is 3
times 0.1 then 20 percent of the time
X is 3 and Y is also 3 so 20 percent of
the time we also get threes in Y then 30
percent of the time
X is 4 which results in a y that's equal
to 4 so we obtain a for 30 percent of
the time and finally 40% of the time x
equals to 4 which results in a y equal
to 4 and we obtain this arithmetic
expression now you can compare the two
arithmetic expressions the red and the
blue one and you will notice that
they're equal except that the terms are
arranged in a slightly different way
conceptually however there's a very big
difference in the first summation we run
over the values of Y one at a time in
the second summation we run over the
different values of x one at a time and
took into account their individual
contributions this second way of
calculating the expected value of y is
called the expected value rule and it
corresponds to the following formula we
carry out a summation over the x-axis
for each x value that we consider we
calculate what is the corresponding Y
value that's G of X
and also way this term according to the
probability of this particular X so for
instance a typical term here would be
when X is equal to two G of X would be
equal to three and the corresponding
probability that the probability of a
two would be a point one the advantage
of using the expected value rule instead
of the definition of the expectation is
that the expected value rule only
involves the PMF of the original random
variable so we do not need to do any
additional work to find the PMF of the
new random variable
now we argued in favor of the expected
value rule by considering this numerical
example and by checking that it gives
the right result but now let us verify
let us argue more generally that it's
going to give us the right answer
so what we're going to do is to take
this summation and argue that it is
equal to the expected value of y which
is defined by that summation so let us
start with this it's a sum over all XS
let us first fix a particular value of y
and add over all those X's that
correspond to that particular Y so we're
fixing a particular Y and so we're
adding only over those X's that lead to
that particular Y and we carry out this
summation so this is the part of this
sum associated with one particular
choice of Y but in order so and it's
some really over this set of X's but in
order to exhaust all X's we need to
consider all possible values of y and
this gives rise to an outer summation
over the different Y's so for any fixed
Y we add over the Associated X's but we
want to consider
all the possible wise now at this point
we make the following observation here
we have a summation over wise and let's
look at the inner summation the inner
summation involves X's all of which are
associated with a specific value of y
having fixed y all the terms inside this
sum have the property that G of X is
equal to Y so G of X is equal to that
particular Y and we can make this
substitution here now when we look at
this summation we now realize that it's
a summation over X's while Y is being
fixed and so we can take this term of Y
and pull it outside the summation what
this leaves us with is a sum over all
Y's of Y and then a further sum over all
X's that lead to that particular Y of
the probabilities of those X's now what
can we say about this inner summation we
have fixed the Y for that particular Y
we're adding the probabilities of all
the X's that lead to that particular Y
fixing Y consider all the X's that lead
to it this is just the probability of
that particular Y but what we have now
is just the definition of the expected
value of y and this concludes the proof
that this expression is given by the
expected value rule gives us the same
answer as the original definition of the
expected value of y now before closing a
few observations the expected value rule
is really simple to use for example if
you want to calculate the expected value
of the square of a random variable then
you're dealing with the situation where
the G function is the square function
and so the expected value of x squared
will be the sum over all X's of x
squared weighted according to the
probability of a particular X and
finally one important word of caution
that in general the expected value of a
function so for example expected value
of x squared in general is not going to
be the same as taking the expected value
of x and squaring it so this is a word
in caution that in general you cannot
interchange the order with which you
apply a function and then you calculate
expectation there are exceptions however
in which we happen to have equality here
and this is going to be our next topic